- Hi, everyone, Sal
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Homeroom live stream.
I'm very very excited
about our conversation
that I'm about to have
with Nikole-Hannah Jones.
But before we jump into the conversation,
I wanna give my standard
announcements reminder.
That Khan Academy is a not
for profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations from folks
like yourself, so if you're
in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy
@khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special
shout out to several
organizations that have stepped up
over the last several months.
We were running at a
deficit even pre-COVID
and then COVID hit and
you can imagine traffic
to Khan Academy has been almost
three X of what's normal.
And so our costs have gone up
and we're trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs,
including this live stream.
So special, thanks to bank of America,
Google.org AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
So with that, I'm super excited to invite
or to introduce a Nikole
Hannah-Jones, a journalist
at New York Times, creator, leader,
founder of The 1619 Project.
Nikole, thanks so much for joining.
- Thank you.
- So there there's a lot to talk about.
And I wanna encourage
anyone who's listening.
You can go on the YouTube or
the Facebook message boards,
and we'll try to surface as
many questions as possible
to Nikole and myself, if it's interesting,
but Nikole, maybe a
good place to start is,
what is The 1619 Project?
And what is the significance of that year?
- Sure, thank you so much
for having me on today.
So The 1619 Project published
a year ago in August
and it is a project that really examines
the modern legacy of slavery.
So it looks at all of
these different aspects
of contemporary American
life and uses history
to trace these various
aspects of our society
back to the institution of slavery
and the anti-black racism that
developed to justify slavery.
So the main premise is that
slavery was foundational
to the United States
and that almost nothing
has been left untouched
by that institution
and our decision to be a country founded
on both ideas of freedom and slavery.
So 1619 is the year
that the first Africans
were sold into colonial America.
It was in that year that a
ship called the White Lion
brought a cargo of between
20 and 30 and Golden's
who had been stolen and
they were sold into slavery
to the Virginia colonists.
So that year marks the
beginning of slavery
in what would become the United States.
- And it's fascinating.
I mean, I've been reading a
lot of what's been written
and it's a whole, it's
not just one article
or one series of writing,
it's even evolving
into a kind of a supplemental
curriculum of sorts.
What did you feel or you and
The New York Times Magazine
feel was the gap?
What was missing in our public knowledge
or the education system?
- Sure, so I guess I should
have said a little bit more
about what the project consists of.
The project is an entire issue
of The New York Times Magazine.
And that issue has about 10
essays written by writers
and historians and each one
examines a different aspect
of American society.
So I wrote the opening
essay that was on democracy.
There's an essay on capitalism,on
why we consume so much
sugar, on why we're the only
Western industrialized country
without universal healthcare, on traffic.
So really the key was we
wanted to surprise readers
who we have been taught when you ask
kind of what's that, what's been absent?
The way that we're typically
taught about slavery
is kinda as an asterix
to the American story.
That it was an unfortunate
thing that we did,
but it wasn't that big
of a part of America
that it's more of a marginal
story that we tell ourselves.
And because of that, we've
never really confronted
what it means to be a nation
that was founded in slavery
and the ongoing legacy.
So what we try to do with
the magazine was again,
to show that whether we
acknowledge that legacy or not,
it operates often invisibly
all across our society
and it has these effects
all across our society.
The project also included a
special section of the newspaper
and that special section
was done in partnership
with the National Museum
of African American History
and Culture in Washington, DC.
And the special section
is really a visual history
of slavery using
artifacts from the museum.
And between those two,
they were complimentary
because the magazine was really
looking at the modern and ongoing legacy.
And the special section
was giving us the history
that we don't get because
we are just so poorly taught
about this history.
The Southern Poverty Law Center.
Research has shown that only
8% of American high school
students even know that the civil war
was fought over slavery.
So I think that gives us
a good idea of how poorly
we've been taught this.
And then the final part of
The 1619 Project is a podcast
and the podcast is called 1619.
And it goes over the
course of five episodes,
several of the areas in
the project that we address
and the reaction has been
really people are very surprised
by what they learned in this project.
They realize how little we've been taught
about an institution that
has had such an influence
on the society that we've become.
- I have to admit, you
know, I considered myself,
someone who's reasonably well
versed in American history.
But the more reading I did,
especially with The 1619
Project, the more I realized
that yeah, I had a thread
of the narrative but not
the complete picture by any
stretch of the imagination.
You know, there's really
interesting things.
And I think, even word choice is sometimes
folk can get skeptical of
all if you call something,
this or that, but you know, when you refer
to plantations, I grew up in Louisiana
and obviously, we had
plantations, people would visit,
we would take family
members down, take pictures,
people have weddings at them.
But you kinda call them for what they are,
forced labor camps.
You point out that the great
majority of the framers
of the constitution own slaves,
many of them lived in homes
and they were continuing to perpetuate it.
Do you think, I've always had at least
maybe a rationalization in my mind,
obviously my family came as immigrants,
but I have always been a kind
of an American exceptionalist,
like look at the enlightenment
and the declaration
of independence, how beautiful this is.
There was clearly this like,
amazing group of people
who came together and they were
imperfect, but they created
something that could become
a more perfect union.
Do you think that the
framers of the constitution
or the founders of our
country, they appreciated some
of the hypocrisy or ironies
or tensions and that maybe
they were uncomfortable with them
or do you think it was
just they compartmentalize
their mind in this in a certain way?
- I think it was both.
Certainly the framers understood
the hypocrisy of arguing
that they deserve to be
liberated from great Britain
while holding 1/5 of a population
in absolute bottom bondage
and chattel slavery.
You know, one of the things we hear a lot
is we shouldn't judge people back then
by today's morals and standards,
but we should be clear.
There was never a time
when we did not know
that it was wrong to
own other human beings,
to force them through
torture, to work for you,
to buy and sell human beings,
to sell children away from their parents.
There was never a time where we didn't
understand that was wrong.
And if you read the writings
of many of the colonists
at that time, for
instance, Thomas Jefferson,
he's really dealing with that hypocrisy.
I mean, he writes that
if there is a just God,
America will pay for
the practice of slavery
and you see that again and
again George Washington
talks about being conflicted over
this really barbaric practice.
But the way that they
dealt with it is really
the way that we still
deal with it in society.
Now we justify it, we kind
of fail to really grapple
with what it means that nearly
half of the founding fathers
owned human beings, that the
reason they had the wealth
and the privilege and
the education to believe
they could break off from the wealthiest,
most powerful empire in
the world at the time,
which was a British empire,
was because of the money and profit
they made off of human slavery.
And we want to downplay that
because it is completely
antithetical to the ideals of this country
and that founding hypocrisy, you know,
if you look at the Federalist Papers,
and you look at how James Madison,
considered the father of the constitution,
they're trying to camouflage
what they're doing.
They are trying to both sustain slavery,
but in their documents
really erase slavery
because they do understand that hypocrisy
and actually Britain and
those who are loyalists
seized upon that hypocrisy
when the colonists were making
their case for freedom.
And they were saying,
well, how can you be making
a claim for freedom when you
trafficking in human beings?
And so a lot of people, when
they read the constitution,
they'll say, well, the constitution
doesn't mention slavery.
It does not, but that
was very intentional.
We all know that the
3/5 compromise is about
how do you count enslaved
people for representation?
And yet you don't see the
word slavery in that document.
So they're doing this kind
of sleight of hand thing,
because what makes America
unique is, it is not unique
that we engaged in slavery.
Yes, it is true that slavery
has an institution last,
you know, predated America
by thousands of years,
that many different cultures
and countries practice slavery.
But we were the only
country founded on ideals
of unalienable rights
of universal freedoms,
that also was founded on slavery.
We didn't just start practicing slavery
at some point in our history.
At our founding, we practiced
slavery while we were saying
that we were a nation built on freedom,
and 10 of the first 12 of our
presidents were enslavers.
They forced people through torture
to labor for them for free,
that's not incidental,
even though we would like
to pretend that it is.
- And you know, one of the
things and some of the imagery
in your writing I think is super powerful.
And I think the imagery really matters.
There's a part in your introductory essay
where you write about Thomas Jefferson,
writing the Declaration of Independence
which you would imagine as
this almost religious moment
in our history, but he was
weighted on in Philadelphia
by one of his slaves who
was his wife's half brother.
- Yes, yes, so when we think about the way
that we are taught history,
what we are not taught,
what is left out is just as important
as what is put in that story.
And so when you're brought
up hearing the story
of Thomas Jefferson writing
the Declaration of Independence
in Philadelphia, the fact
is that yes, he owned 130
human beings on his forced
labor camp in Monticello,
which was built entirely
through forced labor
at the time that he's writing
these universal words of freedom,
some of the most famous words
in the English language,
most of us can say these words
without even having to look at the paper,
we hold these truths to be self evident,
that all men are created
equal endowed by the creator
with inalienable rights.
These are majestic words,
but as he writes them,
he knows that fully 1/5 of a
population in the 13 colonies
will be deprived of all rights,
including his own family members.
So yes, he brings his wife's
half-brother who is a product
of a sexual relationship
with his wife's father.
And one of the enslaved
women that he owned,
which of course by the nature of slavery
was a coerced relationship,
and they own that.
They own their own family members.
And which was a very common
practice that enslavers would
own their own children
as Thomas Jefferson did,
they would own their own cousins.
They would own their
own nieces and nephews.
And he brought his wife's half brother
to Philadelphia with him as
he's gonna draft this document
for the world saying why the
colonists deserve to be free.
And unfree man was taking
care of him and making sure
he was comfortable.
So we have to ask ourselves,
because the pushback of course,
against The 1619 Project has been
why are you rewriting history?
Well, all of these are facts,
but we've only learned
some of those facts.
And it is an intentional
decision that we're gonna talk
about Thomas Jefferson,
but not about the enslaved
relative that he brought with him
or the 130 enslaved people
who are back in Monticello
creating the wealth that allowed him
at the age of 33 or so years old,
to be tasked with drafting of
the document that would allow
us to leave the British empire.
All of these facts matter,
but we're only taught some of those facts.
And the project is attempting to unearth
a more complete story.
- And how do you know,
as you just mentioned,
it has been met with some critics,
some of them very prominent historians.
How do you reconcile?
I have a reconciliation in
my head, I'm happy to share,
but how do you reconcile that?
It seems like we're in this
world where people think
you either have to be ultra proud
and think that your nation's
founding story is perfect
and Holy in every way, or
if you don't believe that
you're the cynic and you're
embarrassed of your country,
isn't there a world where you can do both?
You can be very proud of your country
and where it's come from,
but also know all of its wounds and know
what all of the healing
that's left to be done.
- Of course, it's been
interesting because people have,
some of the critics have said
that The 1619 Project is anti-American.
I don't understand how anyone
can read my opening essay,
which is on how black people,
even though we were not
even considered humans
or citizens of this country,
actually saw those words
of the Declaration and the Constitution,
and believed in them and
fought to make them true.
And how we actually have
helped democratize America.
That that is a patriotic essay that is not
a project or an essay that
says we should hate America,
but we certainly have to be
honest about where we came from.
How do we explain why people
are in the streets right now?
Having to proclaim to this
country that Black Lives Matter?
When black people have
been here for 400 years,
if we don't understand where we came from,
and if we don't understand
that founding hypocrisy
of what it means to be a country
founded in chattel slavery
and ideas of freedom at the same time.
We cannot be afraid of that.
I understand, and we all know that the way
that we're taught history
is really a nationalistic endeavor
It is as any country, the
history you teach yourself
about your own country is
one to uplift the narrative
of who you are as a people.
And to really unite all of
us around a common sense
and shared sense of identity,
but that's simply impossible
without acknowledging
the only reason black people
exist in the United States,
is because of slavery.
And so, because that is so inconvenient,
we're largely just left out
of the story altogether,
but then you can't
understand your country.
You can't understand
who we are as a people,
if you don't understand the entire truth.
- Yeah, I mean, there's just so much even
in your initial essay and much less
than in the entire project,
I mean, even this
notions that were Liberty
from the British empire,
we kind of imagine
this as this oppressive regime
and they may were oppressive
in certain dimensions.
Liberty without representation
and taxing things
like tea and whatever else,
but they abolished slavery
30 years in their colonies,
30 years before we did.
And they didn't do it by
force, they decided to do it.
- That's right, I mean, even
at the time of the revolution,
black people were picking
sides and black people
were picking the side
where they felt they had
the greatest chance of freedom.
So lots of black people at
the time of the revolution
actually fought on and
help beside of the British.
They didn't have loyalty to the colonists.
They didn't have loyalty to the British,
they had loyalty to freedom.
So you have to, again, really think about
what does that mean to be told
a narrative of our founding?
Which is that we were
founded because we believed
in representative government,
that people should be
able to rule themselves,
that everyone should have a
right to choose their leaders.
And yet we were denying all
of that to a large segment
of the population here.
There were lots of motivations
for the revolution.
Some colonists has joined the revolution
because the King had ordered
that they couldn't take
any more indigenous land
and they wanted more land.
Some joined it because they
did believe that people
should have a right to self-governance.
And some joined it
because they were worried
that the British empire
was going to take away
their right to enslave people.
So we just have to get past
these very simplistic narratives
that defy our founding,
that defy our founders.
And one thing that I always ask people
who say, well, you know, slavery was bad,
but you have to look at the whole person.
How would you think of someone who bought
and sold you or your children?
Would you look for the
good side of that person?
Would you say, yeah but look at all
the other great things that person did.
We have to think about that in that way.
I took my daughter to Thomas
Jefferson to Monticello,
right before the COVID shutdowns.
And we got a private tour
and one that really focused
on the enslaved people
who built Monticello.
And we go to the back of the
house and there's fingerprints
in the bricks of enslaved
children who were forced
instead of going to school like
Thomas Jefferson's own children,
these children were
having to through torture
and the threat of violence
build and make the bricks
that would build Thomas Jefferson's house.
You can't ask us to ignore that.
We just have to confront it and be honest
about what that means.
- No it's very powerful imagery.
It's so easy to just have a
few sentences here and there.
But when you really imagine those moments
generation after generation
family separated,
bought and sold, tortured
400 years of that,
then it starts to sink in.
And there's, there's so much,
I obviously I want people
to read, look at the whole project,
but just, even in my
research for this interview,
some of the things that were
just mind blowing to me,
Abraham Lincoln, I think for most of us,
and I will say, still Thomas Jefferson
and Abraham Lincoln are kind of these,
larger than life figures at America.
And Abraham Lincoln, seems to have been
a very forward thinking
person for his time.
But even Abraham Lincoln
was not without issues.
He asked a group of African-American
leaders that if they
were liberated that
perhaps they should leave.
- Yes, Abraham Lincoln until
a few years before his death
leaving colonization.
He believed that black
people were incompatible
with white democracy and
that there were too many
hard feelings and black and
my people were too different.
So the only way that black
people could be free would
be if they were to leave the
United States altogether.
Now keep in mind, of
course that black people
have been in this country
for hundreds of years.
And also through the process of slavery
had lost any connection
to any other country.
So there was nowhere for
black Americans to go back to,
even in the way of European immigrants
or European immigrants all knew
what country they came from,
what language they used to speak,
but black people lost all of that.
So America really was our only
country and the man who we've
all been taught to think
of as a great emancipator.
And he was a great emancipator,
but he was a human being.
He was a man who like most
white Americans at that time,
believed that black people were inferior
and he actually blamed black
people for the civil war.
He actually says to those
men, if you were not here,
we wouldn't be fighting our
white brothers in South,
as a black people wanted to be
in the United States and enslaved.
So again, that your
reaction is the reaction
we've gotten again and
again to The 1619 Project
is I just didn't know, I had no idea.
And I think that that
troubling of the narrative
is so critical because how do we address
the ongoing inequality and
the legacy of that If we don't
acknowledge what actually happened?
If we don't know what actually happened.
- And I think if I say there's
one theme of The 1619 Project
which was really eyeopening for me
is when we learn American
history, we look at, okay some
great words were written on
the Declaration of Independence
and in the constitution.
And in other kinds of
supporting documents,
Federalist Papers, other things
like it, but we say, okay,
but people were of their
time, it was kinda a flawed
history but look those
words helped us evolve
to become a more perfect
union and look at us
decade by decade, although to your point
there was definitely some
regressive moments, but it seems
like we're getting better.
- Well, we're not
- But to your point, we haven't
evolved just because those
words were written in the
Declaration of Independence
or the constitution.
It was a struggle for
essentially Black Americans
over the last 240 years
since our founding to make
those words less
hypocritical or to make them,
all the ironies so that we
get closer to the reality.
I mean, I love this quote from your essay,
"What if America understood
finally, in this 400th year,
so 400 years after 1619,
that we have never been
the problem, but the solution?"
I thought that was a super powerful.
And I'm speaking as an immigrant
who kind of got benefits
from the fruits of us
becoming a more perfect union.
When my family immigrated in
the late '60s and early '70s
explain what you mean by
never been the problem,
but the solution
- Right, so if you do a Google
search on the Negro problem,
the black problem, you will
find an unending number
of articles, whether they
be journalistic articles,
social science articles,
trying to resolve the problem
with black people, what is
wrong with black people?
And I really assert in this
project that there's nothing
wrong with black people.
There's certainly wrong with
a country that would enslave
human beings for profit and
all of the statistics and data
that we use to say that there's
a problem with black people
are perfectly predictable in a country
built on chattel slavery.
But when we think of the
role of black people,
we never think about that
black people have actually been
the primary democratizing
force in this country
that ever since they read those words
of the declaration, they
took those words literally.
They didn't see them as some great ideas
that looked good on paper.
They actually believed that
all men and women are created
equal and that every human being
is entitled to universal rights.
And you see them using this
language of universal rights
before anyone else is really using it,
even before the declaration.
So we think about this history,
it has been Black Americans
through bloody struggle
after bloody struggle
in the United States
against their own countrymen
have fought really to
make those ideas true.
The period after the civil
war known as reconstruction,
which is this brief
12-year period where we see
this large expansion of rights.
We get the end abolishment of slavery
with the 13th amendment,
the 14th amendment,
which is the equal protection
of the constitution.
And then the 15th amendment,
which says you can't deny
people the right to vote
because of their race.
This all comes because of the organizing
of formerly enslaved people
to ensure equal rights
for anyone regardless of race.
And then you see that what
we know as the civil rights
struggle, which once again through the law
is trying to end legal
discrimination and force the country
to live up to its founding ideals.
Today, we're burying one
of the greatest Americans
that this country has produced.
And without someone like John Lewis
and Dr. King and Diane Nash.
We couldn't call ourselves a democracy
because this was a country
that was going abroad
and fighting fascism, fighting Nazis,
fighting other countries to
democratize them while brutally
denying democracy to its own citizens.
Even your own story,
your family being able
to immigrate here in the late 1960s,
early '70s is because of the
black resistance struggle.
Prior to 1965, this country
had a racist immigration quota system.
And it denied nearly
all immigrants of color
from entering the United States
in order to keep the
United States more white
because of the civil rights movement,
we passed the 1965 immigration
and nationalization act,
and it ends that racist
immigration quota system.
And that's when you start to
see large numbers of Asian,
African and South American
and Caribbean immigrants being
allowed into the U S for the first time.
And on top of that, when
your family finally got here,
because of the black resistance struggle,
all legal discrimination
was ended through the law.
So you were not only able to come,
but to enter into a country
where it was no longer legal
to discriminate against you
because of your race or national origin.
And this was all because of
the black resistance struggle,
but we're not taught
that history that way.
And we're not taught that
history in a way that not only
were black people fighting
for their own rights,
but they were fighting to democratize
and make equal our entire country.
Just the last point I'll add on that.
I make this point in my essay,
every other marginalized
group, whether it be a women,
whether it be those who are disabled,
whether it be gay Americans
or immigrants have all used
the tools and the tactics
and the rights expansions
of the black civil rights movements
to expand their own rights.
And probably the best
examples of that is when
the Supreme Court ruled
that the gay marriage was constitutional.
They use the 14th amendment
equal protection clause
pushed by formerly enslaved
in order to make that ruling.
And when recently the Supreme Court ruled
that it was illegal to discriminate
against gay Americans and employment,
they use the 1964 Civil
rights Acts, pushed again
through the resistance
and civil rights struggles
of black Americans to make that ruling.
So when I made that sentence,
I was simply arguing we are all taught.
And I actually think for
immigrants that is part
of the Americanization process
is to be taught
anti-blackness to be taught
that black people are a problem.
And you have to separate
yourself from these problematic
people if you want to succeed in America,
when in fact we have
then the equalizing force
in this country and what
would it mean if we thought
about black people in that way?
- I think that's so powerful,
I will say very openly coming
from an immigrant Asian community,
the community does not realize this.
I've gotten into arguments
at Thanksgiving dinners
saying you don't realize.
And I think there's sometimes a narrative
and immigrant community is
like, look, we came here,
we just had $8 in our pocket
and look at what we did.
Well, first of all you were
kinda creamed off the crop,
cream of the crop but in
that country where you got
the education, et cetera, et cetera.
You came, you did not
have 400 years of families
being torn apart, being torn away
from your cultural legacy,
et cetera et cetera.
And then you were able
to come to this country
really on the foundation
that you just laid.
You're absolutely true.
I mean my father immigrated
this country in 1968.
Exactly for the reasons you
came, he came, he was a medical
professional and we had
a shortage at the time,
but if he would not have
been allowed to come
five or six years before that,
and all of what applies around
segregation and everything
would have likely applied to my father
we don't know.
- Absolutely.
We weren't allowed.
So I think a lot of the
immigrant communities
need to internalize how
much of what we have
has been built on this foundation.
I do wanna make sure that
we get so many incredible
questions coming out.
So from Facebook, Carol Smith Kapur says,
what is your reaction to
Tom Cotton's assertion
that The 1619 Project is going
to lead to racial division.
- We have a white nationalist president
in the White House right now
and for more than two months,
we've had people marching in
the streets trying to make
the statement that Black Lives Matter.
So we are in racially
divided country already.
We know that Donald Trump won
with virtually all white supports.
He lost the majority of
black, Asian, Latino,
and native voters and
he has run on a pretty
openly racist campaign.
So when Tom Cotton says
something like that,
it's not anything that I take seriously.
What he's really saying
is if we actually tell
the truth about our country,
that is something that we
can't handle as Americans.
And that's divisive,
but I don't think confronting the facts
about who we are is ever
going to be divisive.
And in fact, you cannot heal
a racial rift if you ignore
what has caused it.
- Yeah and I'll just underline that.
I mean, I'm confused by comments
like that because
especially The 1619 Project,
the way that it was done,
it is really just knowledge
and information about our shared history.
And it's kind of like,
I don't want to make,
when you have a good friend,
but there's something
that's kind of inside of you.
And one of them that they
have a problem with it doesn't
help anyone to just
sweep it under the rug.
It's always healthy, any
psychotherapist will tell you,
it's healthy to say look, this
happened, this is a reality.
We need to talk about it.
And I think that's all this
project is, it's not saying
don't be incredibly proud of your country
don't be patriotic, it's saying the most
patriotic thing we can do
is to really understand
our good, the bad, the ugly,
the same thing about your family.
All of our families,
we have great stories.
We have not so great stories,
we have to own all of them.
And then we actually become a family,
I think is really what's going on here.
Maybe let's see one more question
or one or two if you have time.
From Facebook, Adrian T. White says,
"As a black man in the South,
I remember our elementary
school teacher only gave us
about one chapter about slavery
and indentured servitude.
And we didn't get to learn about our past.
I even remember the publisher
of our social studies
book, Houghton Mifflin.
How can we help neutralize
some of the systemic plans
to leave us out of the conversations?
It's so empowering to
know where you came from
and I'll just add, do you think
this is intentionally done?
Or do you think it's just kind
of built kind of a momentum
of itself and it's it's unintentional
or it's kind of a combination?
- I definitely think it's intentional.
The history is available, so
nothing in The 1619 Project
that I just singlehandedly unearth.
We got everything from
studying the history books
that have been written about this.
But when you think about
again, what is the role
of US history as taught in K-12 education?
And it is to create a
shared national narrative.
So you necessarily are
playing up the parts
that glorify your country
and you're playing down
the parts that do not.
So you don't get very
much about what happened
to native people, you don't
get very much about slavery.
There's a great deal of discomfort,
with actually dealing
with what that means.
And I do think that's intentional.
I talk about a lot how I took my first
African-American studies course.
It was an elective course in high school
and how transformative
that class was for me,
because in that one
semester, I learned more
about the history and
contributions of people,
of African descent than I had learned
in my entire education
up until that point.
And it's a very demeaning
thing to be taught
that the only contributions
black people ever made
is someone owned them.
And then this great white man freed them.
And then that's the end of your story.
And so to have a different view of that,
and a more full history
and I wish there could be
a 1619 project for indigenous people
and their stories as well.
And for Asian people, there's
just, the beauty of America
is it is this great multiracial nation.
And it was founded on these amazing ideas.
We just fail to live up to them.
And the most patriotic thing
you can do is to fight,
to make those ideals real and true,
not to ignore all of the failings.
So I think one thing that we
have done with The 1619 Project
is we partner with the Pulitzer
Center on Crisis Reporting,
and they've created an
entire free curriculum.
And that curriculum is
available at the Pulitzer Center
and teachers all across
the country are using
that to supplement the standard
curriculum that they have
to give students a broader perspective,
but also just to teach them the question.
So every time you're
exposed to a narrative
that you hadn't heard before,
you don't have to believe that narrative,
but it should cause you then to question,
what are we taught and why and
what am I not being taught?
And hopefully to seek out more
knowledge and Khan Academy
is such a great stage for us
to have this conversation,
because that is exactly
what you're built on,
is helping people to seek out knowledge
and different ways of
understanding things.
And that's what we're trying
to do with the project as well.
- That's so powerful and
maybe one last question.
This is I think an interesting,
forward-looking question.
For actually there's two
questions here related
from YouTube, AZ asks,
why do you think people
still have a racist mindset?
And do you think racial
equality will ever be possible?
I was also asked, do you
think Martin Luther King's
dream will come true?
And we will be, you know, race
won't matter at some point
or will be racially equal?
- So those are two kinds
of separate questions.
Do I think that racial
equality is possible?
Yes, of course it's possible
because the racial inequality
that we see is not natural,
it's not inevitable,
it was created and it's sustained.
So if we chose to make a different choice,
if we decided to put in
the type of resources
to undoing inequality as
we did to creating it,
then we certainly could get rid of it.
But do I think that will do that?
Well, you know, The 1619
Projects is celebrating
the 400th year of this struggle,
and now the 401st year and
black people are still trying
to fight to say our lives
matter, that we shouldn't be
killed by the police,
black people are dying
at the highest rates from
COVID, black people have
the highest rates of
unemployment right now.
The highest rates of people who
are unable to pay their rent
and mortgage, because of COVID.
So I don't think that if we
are not willing to confront
our past and then to do
something very expensive,
to address the disadvantage,
that created this disadvantage
that we will ever achieve equal society.
But we certainly are all charged
with trying to help us get
closer to the society that I won't say
that our founders envisioned,
but that our founders laid down on paper.
- I think that's a very
very very powerful ideas.
And it'll be clear something
that we have to work for.
Nikole, thank you so much for joining.
I think, just in the research
for this conversation,
I learned so much and
obviously talking to you,
that's so much depth and
texture really appreciate it.
Thank you for all the
work you've been doing.
I mean before The 1619 Project,
but especially The 1619 Project,
I think is an important part
of our collective education.
- Thank you so much for hosting me.
- So everyone, thanks again
for joining the live stream.
As you could see, a really
powerful conversation
with Nikole and The 1619
Project, I learned a lot.
I thought I knew a lot
about American history
and my big takeaway here is
if I continue to be confused,
why anyone would believe
that learning more about our
history with somehow polarize
or somehow demean our history.
It gives us more and more ownership
from where we come from collectively.
And so I think projects like
this are not only important.
I think they're essential, so
thanks so much for joining.
And I look forward to seeing
y'all I think next week
on this live stream, see you then.
(logo chiming)